this last year has hit the nhs hard and
not just
on the covered front line non-covid
services have been badly affected too
by the end of february this year 4.7
million people were waiting to start
nhs treatment the highest figure since
records began
over the next half hour i'll be speaking
to a special panel of guests about what
life's been like
if your case was de-prioritized because
of the pandemic
let's introduce them all now i'm joined
by craig whose daughter kelly died from
bowel cancer in june last year after her
treatment
was interrupted antoinette is living
with blood cancer
and cancelled appointments and changes
to her medical care have seen it spread
further
cara is a mental health nurse and eating
disorder patient
her treatment was temporarily cancelled
due to covid and her therapy moved
online
kevin and donna have an autistic son and
the changes of the last year have caused
an enormous amount of stress
to their family ab bridget's son tom
suffered a devastating injury to his
spine last year
covid has meant he's been offered less
than a fifth
of the physiotherapy rehab he needs to
make the best
possible recovery hello to all of you
thank you so much for
joining the panel this afternoon craig i
want to start
with you and your daughter kelly tell us
about her
kelly was a very bright very beautiful
young woman
she had a six-year-old son
and she was the kind of person when they
walked in a room that room would light
up
uh she had a tremendous sense of humor
tremendous sense of fun
and was a very committed mum as well
and she was diagnosed with bowel
cancer she'd been going through
treatment
and then in march of last year
as the covid crisis was unfolding here
what happened
she went into hospital as usual for for
chemotherapy
and went through the process of having
the bloods checked
and just before chemotherapy was due to
start
she was told by the the doctors that due
to covid
they weren't going to treat her and they
recommended that she went home
for 12 weeks to to self-isolate
in order to protect herself from the
disease and by early may
she was then given the prognosis of two
to four weeks to live
and she died on the 13th of june last
year
what impact did that pause in her
treatment have i mean we all know
when it comes to cancer the importance
of getting treatment in a timely
fashion what
impact did kovid have on kelly
i think the principal impact is the the
chemotherapy was never going to be a
cure
kelly was initially diagnosed as stage 4
anyway but what the chemotherapy was
doing was effectively holding the cancer
at bay so even though it was still
spreading it was very very slow
and kelly had always responded very well
to chemotherapy
so once that was actually stopped there
was
nothing effectively holding the cancer
back
at which point it spread throughout her
entire body
very very quickly um and like i said
within
six weeks it got to the point where
there was nothing
that could be done other than palliative
care for her
she was living with you at the time
but it got too much and she had to go
into a hospice at the end which is
something you didn't want to happen
wasn't it
absolutely uh me and my wife and i
um we did the very best that we could uh
obviously we were under
lockdown restrictions and we did have
some excellent support from macmillan
and also from the district nurses
but it got to a point where kelly was
she was in pain and the due to the
liver failure the swelling on the brain
meant that uh cognitive skills were very
badly impaired
and she was sort of effectively a risk
to herself at that point
and as her son was uh living with us we
really didn't want him to see that so we
did eventually arrange
for her to go into a hospice on friday
the 12th of june
and she died 14 hours later
and to compound the agony of that
because of coronavirus restrictions
craig
you weren't able to be with her at the
end
correct the the hospice she went into
were actually very good because there
was meant to be
a 48-hour period after a patient was
admitted
before they could have visitors but the
hospice obviously assessed ellie and
realized that she didn't have lung at
all
so they allowed my wife to to visit her
on the afternoon
she was admitted and then they called
her at four o'clock the next morning
to say that the end was very close but
uh because of the restrictions my wife
had to go through that
on her own as i was not allowed to be
there
devastating for all of you for you and
your wife and and for kelly's
little boy how is he doing now
uh he is remarkably resilient
we still see a lot of him because we
help out
his father with the child care uh
just to try and make sure that he has
some stability and also to
you know for for finn's father it's a
major transition for him as well so
we're all working together
and trying to make sure he feels safe
and loved and he's coping remarkably
well
oh craig for now thank you for for
telling us your
experience and kelly's story let's bring
in antoinette
now anthony antoinette you having
incurable
blood cancer what has covid meant for
you
um kobe's meant for me um
causing my treatment um well i was
supposed to start
a particular treatment which would have
meant me coming up to the hospital
about three times a week um
but because of kobe's my doctors felt it
was better that i went on a
tablet-based chemo treatment which would
mean obviously just taking tablets at
home with fewer hospital visits
i went i started on this particular
treatment
but unfortunately it didn't do
very well for me my cancer unfortunately
progressed
quite rapidly
[Music]
it spread to my spine
and it collapsed um
vertebrates as well as caused which i
recently found out instead of having
four fractures i have
13 fractures as a result of the
progression
um even though they tried to prevent me
from coming into hospital
it turned out that i was actually
admitted for
three and a half weeks and i had many
admissions after that even during the
coboot
crisis and you are living
in severe pain now antoinette
yeah um the pain i just there's
no words i can describe um i've been
referred to palliative care
for the pain i am in the back race
um to try and help me to support my body
um and help with the pain um
i need physiotherapy but obviously
because of kovid
i've had no physiotherapy at all
um so this is the position i'm in at the
moment
you're on i think is it your 17th cycle
of chemotherapy
i've actually had more than 17 cycles in
total this
is my 10th cycle but i've had five lines
of treatment
over these nine years so
i've had at least 30 cycles of
chemotherapy
throughout my lifetime and if it hadn't
been for the pandemic how different
would your treatment plan have been and
your expectation of where you would be
now
antoinette well um
i would have been able to start the
original treatment that i was supposed
to start
and the progression may not have
happened
and even if it did i would have been
able to
the doctors would have been able to take
care of the orthopedic side
of my back like my spine
um i've only seen got to see
the orthopedic doctor twice
my appointments just kept being put back
um because of covered
you know and shorted years um so
i have not you know i i should not be in
the brace
now um basically
uh antoinette thank you let's bring in
cara
now cara you have had anorexia for
more than half of your life you had a
relapse in the the latter
part of 2019 is that right and you were
getting treatment
then what happened um so i was in an
intensive treatment program which is
sort of sits between inpatient and
outpatient services so i was going to
the clinic
every day for supported meals and
therapy groups
and then we just went in one day and
were told that was the last day that we
could be there and that was the day that
we went into the national lockdown
and then ever since then everything that
i did was virtual
that shift to doing treatment virtually
how did that affect you was it helping
in the same way as you'd hoped it might
no definitely not um my individual
therapy
was brilliant and i think that they did
really the best that they could in
really difficult circumstances but
going from sort of daily support and
having all my meals supported and having
them portioned out by a dietitian and
things like that to them suddenly having
to manage
that at home by myself was really
difficult um
and i was also only about halfway
through the program when that happened
so i had to do the other half of all my
weight restoration at home
by myself um all my like meal planning
and portioning and things like that i
then had to do all by myself and i
hadn't had to do that for
quite a number of months um
independently up until that point so to
then have to go and do that by myself
overnight it's really challenging
and i wonder how much effect is social
isolation is in compounding
what you're already going through
uh really significant yeah um i think
eating disorders just really thrive in
that sort of environment of being
socially isolated um so it kind of like
i didn't just lose my professional
support network i lost kind of all my
personal support network at the same
time so i felt like i kind of went
from having this really intensive
support from sort of every
area of my life to having almost nothing
it felt like
you also work as a mental health nurse
so you know
firsthand the pressures that the system
was already
under now we know that eating disorders
in both adults and children have soared
during
the pandemic how is it going to be able
to cope
in the months years ahead
that's a really good question and i
honestly don't know i think there needs
to be a significant increase in funding
particularly
into adult eating disorder services
because they do seem to lag
quite far behind and without that i
honestly don't know how they're going to
kind of be able to pick up
the fallout from covered
yeah and as we can hear from all of your
stories that that fallout
is hugely significant let's bring in
kevin
and donna uh your son angus was
diagnosed with
autism last month what impact does
coronavirus had
on him
um we had a really big impact as soon as
we went into lockdown really because
his whole world changed and his
environment changed and we hadn't
um at that point we hadn't got to
diagnosis which made it a bit more
difficult but
his whole world changed really um we had
to change the house in terms of getting
everybody working space so he could work
from home and we could work from home
um his routines changed
everything just completely shifted
really
until he sort of relaxed into it and
then
we got into back into routine um
[Music]
but then towards sort of june he was
back in and out of school so again it
was
um changing routine backwards and
forwards again and i think he felt very
overwhelmed
um from a social aspect he was quite
happy to be at home and i think
if he'd have stayed at home that would
have been fine um it was
the constant in and out and the changes
to his environment
yeah it's interesting you say that
actually isn't it because while
homeschooling was difficult for many
actually in angus case being in a
familiar environment with that stability
of of home without a lot of unfamiliar
people around
reassuring and yet those transitions the
lack of routine the constant change
very very difficult to deal with
yeah he did he felt extremely
overwhelming and
we had quite a few problems um we didn't
realize at the time he'd been
self-harming
from almost since lockdown started um
he had alerted school at one point that
he was having some problems but we just
thought it was anxiety
um and then um in september when they
went back again
um it became very apparent he actually
went to the nurse and said he was having
a lot of problems
um and then he's self-harmed at school
so that was a very big crisis point
for us and what about that that process
of getting a formal
diagnosis for him and then the
subsequent support that is necessary
well the diagnosis and um the cams for
his mental health
issues were two separate um
the services really so for the for the
uh diagnosis with that been going on
since
before christmas 2019 and it normally
takes around two years
for a diagnosis so i think we did okay
to get through in 18 months but
um when um we did have this emergency
um self-harming issue when we rang up
the autism team they had to refer us to
the cams
team for young people um who then
got the young duty um therapist to call
us
and gave us some safeguarding helps us
put a safety plan in place
um but then it wasn't until after
it was about four or five weeks or after
we had an absolute crisis after the
school
incident that we got any help um we were
just told to go out to a e
which um again is very difficult
which we didn't feel was the right thing
but we would have done
yeah very difficult decisions that
you've been having to make kevin i
wonder how you
and donna have coped during this period
with
the fear the uncertainty and this very
long
process to get to a diagnosis
i i think it is the change that has
affected all of us the
chopping and changing between lock down
back into school out again
back out again and and that that sort of
constant change has meant
that for i'm autistic as well and and so
for me and angus
uh there's no there's no time to settle
into a new routine
before it's changed again but also not
having a diagnosis meant that we
couldn't access the services
that we needed to and to get the support
we needed
and is that support there now donna
um i would like to say yes but i don't
think it is we are referred
um i know
um in short for young people there is an
uh
we have a fantastic group called space
autism in mackelsfield who
um cams refer to but space for aren't
commissioned to
provide these kind of services for young
people and we really need candles
support and help
uh kevin and donna thank you let's bring
in bridget bridget you have also
been battling to try and get the right
kind of care for your son tom now
tell us about tom he had a horrific
accident last summer what happened
he had a serious spinal accident he
dived into a swimming pool
and was taken to kings for four and a
half months but because of covid the
staff were exhausted he then became
extremely ill
it took us four and a half months to get
them to his final unit but there is
currently almost no provision so
all certain young adults but i believe
um
adults with a serious spinal injury are
now sent to
um care homes often geriatric care homes
where there's no rehab facilities at all
so we have hair homes tom's a 20 year
old man
yeah and then and so you're in a
geriatric care home because of course
there are currently a lot of space
in in care homes and they they need
funding as well
and so a direct result of coverage is
that young adults like tom are in
completely inappropriate settings where
they get they receive no rehabilitation
so tom was expected after 12 weeks in
state mandatory to go to a care home
where there would be no rehab
so we've had just a massive fundraising
campaign
um and then he caught code in hospital
and was in complete isolation for five
weeks when he saw nobody um because the
hospitals are at
breaking point and it's part covered
it's part of reaction to being
underfunded in the first place but they
have
very little money and they've got almost
room for maneuver
so we we took we've had to get him his
rehab center in sheffield which is five
hours away from us and we
fight every day to get the funding for
him and if i
can apologize for saying please look at
tomlasarudis.com
where you'll see his story and what
we're trying to do for him and everybody
else for the spinal injury
of his age that needs looking after
yeah we're looking at pictures of tom
now before the accident
he was incredibly sporty active young
man
to find yourselves now in this position
and then the frustration of not being
able to get him the help that
he needs how has that affected you
well i think you know he's got three
siblings and everybody has just
one realizes that one's life spins on on
top of a coin and we have to fight and
fight and fight to get him
the rehab that he needs so we can get
him home it's even a fight now to get
him home because there's nuke over
all the practice and you have to show
that home is a better environment than
being in a care home
you don't know what the you have no idea
what the criteria for that is because
you're not supplied with any of this
documentation so we're
currently fighting to get them home but
one can't get an occupational therapist
into the house to come and see if it's
suitable so it's just a constant battle
yeah so not only this battle for
treatment but also
that separation from your son at a point
when
he needs his family the most and you
want to be with him
but also when listening to everybody
else's stories because one feels very
much like you're
completely isolated and then you hear
about the trauma of people
not being able to access cancer
treatment or mental health treatment i
mean there are so many others within the
situation and
and it's very hard to get one story out
and to
one is constantly fighting our gp was
brought up sorry our gp is brilliant our
mp has been absolutely fantastic helen
hayes
but you fight every day to try to get
him home and try and get the treatment
that he needs
and i think what is so devastating is
when we look at the figures we hear your
stories individually
so traumatic and yet they are not in
isolation by any
stretch of the imagination craig if i
can come back
to you to be going through this
unimaginable tragedy that the grief that
you've gone through in a point at which
we are kept away from support networks
from family from friends from loved ones
how have you coped
the principal thing we've done to the
characters to try
and make at least a small amount of good
come out of kelly's loss because what
has happened to her
is unfortunately not an isolated
incident
so we started a campaign last year like
or
catch up with cancer to to
ask the government to put the necessary
funds in place
to support cancer services because even
at that point
the prediction was that 35 000 cancer
patients would die
due to lack of treatment and we've been
working on this
ever since we've got 400
000 signatures on a petition we've got a
letter
signed by for over 400 doctors and
oncologists
we have the support of hundreds of mps
yet the latest response from the
government
is this campaign is basically we're just
a bunch of scare numbers
which to me is well it's disrespectful
and
also grossly inaccurate considering you
know what we're actually trying to do
um council research uk recently released
figures that indicated that over 43 000
people
are walking around with cancer and they
don't even know yet because they can't
get onto the cancer pathway
so what i would say really to the
government is
follow kelly's example be active do
something about this
try and help to the point where if if
the government feel that we are
genuinely a bunch of irrational scammers
then i would invite matt hancock and
simon stevens to join me
and professor pat bryce to debate this
in public on live tv we have the
strength of our convictions and we have
the data to support that
so we feel that we can put a rational
case across
to help cancer patients yeah you raised
a really important point craig that it's
not just
existing cancer patients as it is those
that that haven't yet got a diagnosis
are either too
frightened to go and try and see
a doctor and get a diagnosis or are
waiting
for those diagnosed diagnostic
procedures
and antoinette a final thought
from you aside from
the knock-on effect this has had on your
medical treatment what about the mental
health
implications of this going through this
when your access to those broader
support networks
are is taken away
it's just been horrendous i mean my
family and friends know me
to be genuinely a strong person but this
has to be aside the treatment one of the
hardest things i've ever had to deal
with in my life
lucky for me um i managed to find
a charity called aclt who
you know i could i thought i could just
pick up the phone and just call
at any time because you know i just
started to feel
that you know i didn't want to keep
bothering you know family and friends
um all the time because they had their
own
problems and struggles to deal with um
so
mentally this has really affected me
mentally and not just me
i have two young children as well um so
for them
it's just been um you know a massive
impact
on me myself and my family
cara i wonder how you are
now and what your hopes and needs are
as we begin to emerge from lockdown
as the the world starts to open up again
what do you need to support you
um i'm doing okay actually so i was
discharged in march
for what i hope is the final time i've
been under the service a few times now
um i feel relatively confident that i'll
be able to stay out of the service now
that i've kind of managed to navigate
recovery in such
difficult circumstances um so i guess
what i need is for the world to open
back up
as safely as it can in order to sort of
build up my
support network that exists outside of
mental health services
and take things slowly cara we wish you
all the very best for that ongoing
recovery thank you
to all of you for sharing your stories
with us today
uh craig antoinette cara
kevin and donna and bridget thank you
all very much
indeed it is not just the impact that
this has had on the covered front line
within the nhs
so many people have been affected by
treatment by support being paused during
the pandemic